so i find that if you can trigger
you know you get things started by
listening in the morning
then you just have to circle back later
on hi there steve kaufman
today i want to talk about my morning
routine
what do i do in the morning to get my
language learning activities started for
the day remember if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe click on the
bell for notifications
and if you follow these as podcasts on
spotify or apple podcast or elsewhere
please leave a review so people often
ask me sort of specifically what do you
do
to learn the language okay
the morning is a big part of my language
learning day
if you can get stuff done in the morning
first thing that kind of sets you up for
the day
so that even if it's not a very active
day
from a language learning point of view
at least you've taken that first step i
might first of all just kind of review a
couple of lessons
on my ipad from the day before in
whichever language i'm learning and
nowadays it's either arabic or persian
but then okay time to get out of bed
here
so
i will set up in a room where it's quiet
and my wife doesn't have to listen to me
uh where i will play
something that's easy to listen to like
the mini stories for example even though
i've listened to them many times
or something that's new and fresh like a
podcast that i've just downloaded
so i'll put that on and that's now
running in the background
then i go to my
muscle booster
website where i have this
seven minute routine okay which consists
of sit-ups and push-ups and burpees and
stretching and and you know side planks
and there's a there's a range of things
and they mix them every day i don't know
what's coming at me next it's all in 30
second intervals
and it's extremely good by the way and
so for seven minutes i will be doing
these exercises 30 seconds 30 seconds 30
seconds while this
arabic or persian is running in the
background okay
then typically if it's the summer now i
go for a swim in the ocean and the water
is like 16 17 18 degrees depending on
the day so that really wakes you up i
can tell you
uh 16 i don't know what that is in
fahrenheit it's in the 60s i think
um
around 60.
so
then uh
time for breakfast so typically i go in
i'll cut up fruit start preparing we
have muesli
i get you know i have to make some i
make my espresso coffee so i grind some
coffee beans
set the table
uh and all the while i'm listening okay
if the
dishwasher
was full from the night before we just
run the dishes i'll go in and empty the
dishes in other words
preparing for breakfast and then also
cleaning up after breakfast is at least
a half hour of listening
most days
i will be doing that activity
and listening to my language okay
now
then maybe and it has been the case that
i tend to have my
my arabic online tutor sessions around
10 10 30 in the morning
and right now uh
muhammad seems to have disappeared at
italki so i have
adele sami
and so that we'll have an hour there
uh two times a week
uh
then very often my wife likes to play
golf so we've got golf set up at 12 30
or one so we charge off to the golf
course
if if i weren't in the car with my wife
i'd be listening to arabic or persian
but you can't you know there's a limit
right there's a limit i can't do that
uh so then when i come home
but i wanted to focus on my morning
routine because now i have set myself up
for the day so when i come home i need
to find another half hour
or so maybe an hour to sit down to go
through whatever it was i listen to
and save words and phrases or review
words and phrases or read it
so that i basically pick up the pieces
from what i started in the morning
but the morning is very important first
of all the the seven minute exercise
routine which is great
um
throwing myself in the water
sure jars the brain cells
and then spending some time
you know with the language listening
every so often i have to you know vacuum
or clean up or do other activities
around the house there again i'll be
listening so a lot of that stuff happens
in the morning
now
other people have other things happening
in the morning like they might be going
off to work but there again there's an
opportunity in a car or on a train or a
subway to listen to language so i find
that if you can trigger
you know you get things started by
listening in the morning
then you just have to circle back later
on
and go and find those things you're
listening to where maybe you're curious
about certain words or expressions that
you kind of half know or completely
don't know and you can look them up and
start on the process of learning them
so i just thought i'd mention that my
approach to the morning is is to make
that
you know a place to get a start on the
day whether it be through my physical
exercise if i have later if i have time
also with the exercise if i come home
from the golf and i have time i might
get on my uh
stepper or nordic truck or go for a run
down at the schoolyard or do something
else uh maybe lift some weights or
use the trx you know band or something
like that but at least i've got in that
seven minutes of exercise in the morning
and also at least i've got in that half
an hour or 45 minutes combined listening
in the morning to get a start on the day
from a language learning point of view
so i hope that was of interest and look
forward to your comments bye for now